the question was I gave you two fixed
points to fix points I think they were
the trees right and then I said I would
like you to position yourself such that
you are twice as far from one fixed
point one tree as the other twice is far
from one as the other and because that's
something which you don't have like a an
inbuilt geometric definition for you're
like what on earth is that shape
we really struggled to come up with that
shape and so here is where while algebra
can be somewhat tedious at times you
gain insight that you can't just get by
intuition and then once you can replace
with intuition then you don't need to
worry so much about the algebra so I've
just picked out a couple of points this
is the point we've been continually
using this morning just because why not
and this is another point which I've
chosen carefully I'll actually have a
think about as we go through why I've
chosen the particular point that I have
and then lastly what's this guy again
this guy is very important to this topic
this guy is our it's a point that moves
it's a point that can change its
coordinates so long as it keeps on
adhering to the the geometric rule or
definition or property that I've
provided okay so if I want the distance
to a to be twice as far as the distance
to be then how would I state that in an
equation what we're actually right okay
so I could say distance B times two
equals distance a that would be fine
excuse me I should point out that while
that's totally okay at the moment it's
slightly ambiguous because like we're
distance from beetle to dowhat right
distance revita Hey would that make
sense that's a fixed distance so using
the notation I already have what could I
say in step which would mean the same
but excuse me would be unambiguous as to
what's going on Michael
to be P equals a P what do you think
these these say the same thing don't
they so neither is better than the other
but seeing as I've named P the moving
point I might as well use that name okay
now these are both businesses between
two points very good at doing the
distances between two points so let's go
ahead and actually start to work out
what these numbers are going to look
like I'm gonna need a bit more board
space so I'm gonna start at the top I
begin with a two and then here comes
this big square root right so what's
underneath the square root you tell me X
X plus two because of the double
negative squared and then plus y plus
three squared again because of the
double negative you happy with that so
there's the left-hand side that's two
times B P on the right hand
alternatively we have the same deal but
my numbers are just ever so slightly
different okay so you go ahead
you took your square root in what's this
X minus ya doing okay right now so all
I've done is I've taken the geometric
definition and put algebra underneath it
okay but now this is the power of
algebra right you don't know what these
things are but you can still work with
them when you see these square roots
what is your instinct Square and get rid
of them okay now we will do exactly that
but just be cautious there's not just
square roots on both sides this guy is
also hanging around and if you square
everything you're gonna square here as
well so on the left hand side I think
I'm gonna get this I suppose I could
have just written the four all the way
out the front and then put big chunky
brackets but I'm gonna need to do some
expansion in a minute so I'm just gonna
leave that as it is okay over on the
right hand side we get this sans the
square root sign okay to have a look
think before you write what's the best
way to go next in order to simplify this
what's the most efficient way
fantastic so we are going to have to do
some expansion shortly but let's do
things before we expand because
expanding always makes things Messier
and you can see I already have this like
term on both sides I might as well deal
with that first when you have a look at
the X's you're gonna have to expand
those in some ways they're kind of
unlike terms aren't they okay so I am
going to expand those these are the two
things I'm going to do I'm going to
collect like terms with these guys and
then I'm going to begin expanding my X
terms okay so can you help me out for x
what's in the brackets x squared plus 4x
plus 4 okay I'm over on the left hand
side over here I think I'm going to I'll
subtract a y plus 3 or squared I could
avoid negatives so that leaves me with
three of them over here so if I so good
and in the same way I'm going to start
to expand the remaining terms on the
right hand side that gives me x squared
minus 2x plus 1
okay now this looks messy but it's not
impossible to deal with
okay so have a look as you can see how
many X terms I have over here and you
can see they're gonna collect with some
of the X terms over here right
how many x squared terms do I have I
have four here and I have one there so
when I subtract and balance things out
I'm going to end up with how many on
this side three how many X to the one
terms do I currently have on the left
hand side I've 16 of them and then
there's negative two over there so when
I balance things out and I add 2x to
both sides I'll end up with 18x and then
lastly 4 times 4 again 16 what's gonna
happen
15 after I minus 1 okay and then you got
this guy still kicking around and there
is nothing left on the right-hand side
okay
I'm gonna ask the question again there's
a bunch of things I could do what makes
the most sense to get to a simplest part
most efficiently Eric
that's convenient isn't it it's almost
as if someone picked these numbers so
they would be nice and convenient
everything's a multiple the three so I'm
going to divide these through that
leaves me with this five oops that's
going now okay now again pause for a
moment think we've been doing algebra we
have been doing it mindlessly but we've
been doing we just been thinking about
this algebraically right we haven't
really thought about the fact that hey
remember this came all the way from
shapes through geometry through
coordinate geometry now we're in lockers
so we had this great you know foundation
of knowledge that we ought to be drawing
on but we've just been thinking algebra
right now
so think again what does this thing look
like what do you what do you predict
this is going to be this looks to me
like it's gonna be a circle right the x
squared and the y squared is kind of the
smoking gun that tells you that okay so
therefore even though I can factorize
this as it is like these these guys over
here I can factorize that you can
factorize that but I don't want to
there's something else I should do to
these rather than just factorize it as
it is what should I do if it's a circle
I should complete the square shouldn't I
X plus 1 X plus 5 is no use to me
besides the fact that I'm expecting a
circle with an actual radius not a zero
radius so therefore what do I add to
both sides to complete the square to
know what you want over here to know
what you want you need to have this and
square it that should be 9 I already
have 5 so what should I add 4 will get
me there right x squared plus 6x plus 9
this is already completed you added 4 to
the left so you should add 4 to the
right I'm good so far all right I'm
pretty much there
so I'm gonna even write that as two
squared okay does this match
what were we were forming outside not
really cuz admittedly it's not like a
gave you any measuring instruments or
anything like that tell me what this
shape is is this circle and what else
can you tell me about it
center is at negative 3 negative 3
negative 3 negative 3 negative 3
negative 3 just think about that in
relation to these guys before I show you
what it looks like position where a and
B are then position where the center of
this is and then the radius of course is
so are you ready to see it here we go I
only need that part so that's convenient
there's what's that one that's B that's
B that's a ok so here's 3 1 & tree -
yeah do you remember where you would you
remember where you positioned yourselves
do you remember when Jake and drew when
you're like far hipsters to mainstream
to be over here okay are you ready to
see the circle there it is do you see it
can you if you see how it works
you see how every point marvelously
follows the pattern that we were
thinking about there was um there's the
Lazy point right there do you remember
what we were talking about with division
of an interval right because look here's
the ratio 1 to 2 do you see it and then
if you go over to the I'm gonna keep
calling it back if you keep going over
here to the Jake and dhruv spot can you
see how this relates to that have a look
at the distances you see from here to
here that's one to two because of course
these distances are the same right does
that make sense so in some ways what
you've done is you've done an external
ratio Division you're going outside
right one to two and then of course
every other spot because this is
perfectly graphed unlike something I
would do by hand if you pick any spot on
the locus it's just it's marvelous right
look at this that is gonna be double
that every time even when you go to like
a weed spot over here you can go
you can measure from here and you'll get
double pretty sweet right and not what
you necessarily expected okay so I need
to show you that because it's actually a
shape you recognize just this is not at
all the definition you expected that the
algebra shows you it has to be that
right I often think in maths maths sort
of has a lot of moments where it's like
have you ever watched like a film or TV
series and there's like some secret
character and they wear a mask for a
long time or you their voices disguised
and then like three seasons in you're
like OMG it's that person who we always
thought new or long well the circle was
they're hiding this whole time and we
didn't pick it at all did we right but
now arrowmaster so we're going to see
more shapes as we go through lockers the
idea of lockers simply is define a shape
even coordinate geometry based on some
kind of regular geometric rule okay